Try to guess which is the normal ball.
Okay! Ready, set, go!
Well now you can't bend your elbow I think.
No I can't.
I know Otto's weak spot.
There!
It's like tennis backhand almost.
Yeah I thought exactly the same.
Oh beautiful!
I think that's enough.
I want to get out of this.
Fill a ping pong ball full of water.
And we have this massive syringe to do that!
Miikka where did you get this thing?
Maybe halfway.
Normal ball vs water ball.
Try to quess which is the normal ball.
Okay ready, go!
What?!
There's good spin!
And it might bounce.
We're not even gonna get two shots on.
No.
We'll get one rally if we skip the serve
and do like a volley.
Yeah it's working we found it.
We found the feeling.
Almost like normal table tennis.
Maybe lets...
Yeah lets fill it up!
The first dosedidn't have the desired effect so
it's time for injection numbertwo!
I feel like a mad scientist.
Okay lets try it out!
Bouncetest number two!
Actually it might be a bit different because
now ithas no air in it, it's only water.
I mean it could be it could be.
But no.
Whoaa what?!
It sounds like a bouncy ball.
Okay okay yeah!
Ooh I think it cracked!
Yeah it cracked.
He's had enough.
We've also got a lot of suggestions to play with
a frozen table tennis ball
so we're gonna put one of these
in the freezer and try it out!
Oh you received my serve but I didn't receive yours.
Oh that's it! Yeah!
So let's make a bit harder serve now then.
2-0? Yeah i think we got it!
That was quite good!
Lets see how the frozen ball is doing.
Okay this is what happened.
It justexpanded and the ball couldn't take it.
Okay maybe, maybe..
It's melting really..
Whoah!
Aah that's so cool!
Can you see that?
That looks so cool!
Okay we've got to be fast!
Yeah this is melting quick!
Okay zero zero.
Surprise!
That wentpretty much as expected.
Good match guys! Yeah good match!
That was the shortest challengeof the day.
See ya!
Guys go and check out
go and check out pongfinity.store!
Ourwebstore where we have cool ping pong products!
Such as this portable net and
professionallevel ping pong balls!
Until next time!
Ooh the camera man jackpot!